I told you just two days ago that Corona virus
is continuing to ravage, in particular some
parts of the country.
But meanwhile, confusingly, the country is
opening more and more, particularly the parts
of the country that are having the case and
death problems.
We have a planned Tulsa, Oklahoma, Trump rally
with thousands of people on Saturday.
Dr. Anthony Foushee has already recommended
against going to such a rally.
Rally goers, in fact, have to sign a waiver
for corona virus contagion if they want.
Tickets to this Donald Trump rally.
But we now have several more days of data.
And the Corona virus pandemic in some particular
states is spiking so quickly, so quickly and
so aggressively that the numbers almost seem
fake, but they are not fake.
And what I mean is when you look at these
case graphs that I'm going to show you, we
are more than three months into this pandemic.
It's hard to believe that some states are
managing the pandemic so poorly that we are
now getting these spikes like these states
are nowhere near the peaks that some states
reached in early to mid April.
Looking at Texas, for example, I already told
you days ago that cases were spiking in Texas.
That was nothing compared to what we are now
seeing, a record 4000 cases in one day in
Texas yesterday.
These are unconscionable Nung numbers.
Sticking with this part of the country, Arizona
is quickly becoming the hot spot in terms
of case growth rate in the United States.
Also with a record 2400 cases yesterday.
When you look at these charts that they're
downright dystopian, spoke to a friend in
Arizona.
Again, everybody's just acting like nothing's
going on.
He says stores are open.
People packed together.
Nobody's wearing masks.
Just like almost no mitigation going on at
all.
Florida, very similar curve.
Have a lot of friends in Florida very worried.
And again, yesterday, the worst day in Florida
since all of this started.
Also thousands of new cases.
So I really need people to understand the
context here.
We're months into this White House Corona
virus task force in place for months, mitigation
testing, PPE, stay at home orders, wear masks,
indoor months and months and months.
And yesterday was the worst day since the
start of this in Texas, Florida and Arizona.
Now, it's not just red states.
As I've mentioned, California, which was an
early hotspot.
It's still having having problems.
They've not exactly flattened the curve.
But even the growth rates in California are
not.
The erratic numbers that we are seeing in
some other places.
Now, meanwhile, I continue to be really glad
that things are going well in some places.
I'm not saying this to brag.
It's just luck that I mean, I guess it's not
luck.
I live in Massachusetts, obviously, partially.
I live here because my family move here partially.
I live in Massachusetts because I prefer the
politics of Massachusetts to those of some
of these other states.
The case curve here just falling off a cliff.
If you're watching Connecticut doing really
well.
Lots of states are doing very well.
And we'll see as they start to open.
Whether that changes.
So the point here is mitigation works.
The cases and the deaths respond to what people
are actually doing.
The weather does not seem to be stopping the
spread in warmer states.
And as the summer comes and the Trump administration
is just pretending that it's over, things
are actually so bad right now in some states
that this conversation about wave two is essentially
irrelevant in the sense that there's not going
to be a dip.
It seems as though, you know, we had this
idea wave one would be dying off by late April,
early May.
We might have almost no new cases.
By June 1st.
There were models that said by June one, there
will be almost no new cases.
We've got 20000 thousand new cases a day in
some of these states.
There won't be a wave two because wave one
will never end.
Wave two was supposed to start, you know,
maybe September, mid-September.
We're now looking at, at least in some states
that have not even hit their peaks, just a
continued sustained pandemic through the end
of the year if nothing changes the way Texas
is looking, Florida, Arizona.
It's very difficult to imagine with cases
spiking to where they are now, that there
actually will be a dip that we could call
a pause between waves.
We could just have a six or eight or nine
month wave until hopefully there is an effective
treatment and a vaccine.
And half the country seems to be pretending
that everything is fine.
Now, in terms of, you know, what's safe in
different places, I posted a picture of myself
in Massachusetts over the weekend sitting
outdoors at a cafe.
It felt safe, given the numbers here were
down to only, you know, 100.
We had only 58 new cases a couple of days
ago, about 150 a day under 200 people now
left in the ICU in the entire state.
I ordered online.
I grabbed my coffee and bagel.
Didn't do, you know, interact with anybody,
sat outside at a table, nobody around me.
When I leave, I flip a piece of paper on the
table that goes from green to red.
So other people know not to sit there, wait
staff come over and and clean it.
It seems safe.
I mean, the outdoor contagion is primarily
when people are doing obviously stupid things,
crowding together at, you know, on on a hiking
trail or something like that.
It seems like that is relatively safe.
What we're seeing in other states where it's
indoors.
No masks, people on top of each other.
Of course, that's going to lead to spread.
So, you know, we talk about the 80-20 rule.
We talk about 80, 80 percent of people are
incompetent at whatever they're doing.
Most of the rules about even outdoors, you
should look at wearing a mask.
We only need to be doing that because of the
small portion of people that are just doing
stupid things unless you tell them wear a
mask outdoors.
And that is something that we can't ignore.
When we look at state leadership on down.
That's a big part of why some of these states
are having such major problems